Welcome to the show.
So, um, we have been having some, uh, complexities
for [inaudible].
We're
figuring out exactly what should be said in
this segment because of the schedule for filming
this week and the very, very long impeachment
hearings that have been happening in the house
judiciary committee.
Uh, we are having to tape this segment before
we actually know the full outcome and schedule
of what has been taking place.
So what I am saying right now may be outdated
or it may have already happened or it may
be about to happen.
Uh, but I want to kind of give an overview
of what is going to happen with what is the
impeachment of Donald Trump by the house of
representatives currently with a democratic
majority.
Uh, Thursday, very, very long hearings in
the house judiciary committee made up of 41
members in total, 24 Democrats, 17 Republicans
that body, uh, after debating on and on and
on, a variety of amendments, which of course
never had an opportunity to pass, but merely
served as a jumping off point for grand standing.
And for the repetition of what at this point
is very exhaustingly the same talking points
over and over and over again, monopolizing
news television for the entire day.
The house judiciary will or already did vote
among along party lines.
Uh, yes on impeachment of Donald Trump sending
the vote to the full house in the house.
They will or may have already voted basically
along party lines to impeach Donald Trump,
the president of the United States.
Now, what would be interesting and as of this
filming we don't know, but that I would be
curious to see, would be, are there any democratic
members of the house that vote against impeachment
or are there any Republican members of the
house that vote for the impeachment of Donald
Trump?
For example, we had heard at different points
in time that there's a, um, uh, where she
from Hawaii Congresswoman tools he gathered
who at least one point was not in favor of
impeachment.
How does she vote, if at all?
She's been missing from a lot of votes as
well.
Are there any, uh, individuals that cross
party lines?
What then will happen is that the Senate will
have a trial and it appears as though that
is going to be in January.
Now everybody has different interests in how
this trial, um, uh, is going to go or may
go.
The trial will be organized by the Senate
majority leader.
Remember, despite the house being taken over
by Democrats in November, 2018 sworn in January
of this year, the Senate is still controlled
by Republicans and that means that the Senate
majority leader Mitch McConnell gets to set
a lot of the parameters and procedure of how
that impeachment trial goes.
We in looking at the tentative 2020 Senate
calendar, we see that January has been left
blank at least as of this filming with the
expectation that this is when the impeachment
trial is going to take.
I have been asked how long could that impeachment
trial go?
It could be a week to 10 days.
It could be the majority of January.
We just don't know yet.
Donald Trump has reportedly expressed an interest
in it going a very long time.
He believes maybe rightly, maybe wrongly,
that along impeachment trial would be good
for him.
Uh, however, presiding over the impeachment
trial will be the chief justice of the Supreme
court of the United States, which is of course,
John Roberts, a conservative justice, not
selected by president Donald Trump, but a
conservative justice nonetheless.
So then the question is, uh, what is going
to happen in the Senate?
And I will give you some of the counterpoints
to this, but the most likely scenario, I am
not a betting man, but if I were a betting
man, I would imagine that it is going to be
a, uh, an acquittal of Donald Trump in the
Senate.
Why do I say that?
Well, so far we have seen no interest from
Republican senators to seriously even consider
the possibility of analyzing what it is that
has taken place and being open to voting to
convict Donald Trump a priori.
We have seen Republicans dismiss the case
for impeachment, uh, save, you know, these
little, uh, blips that we could maybe talk
about.
Uh, currently the numbers are against Democrats
in the sense that there are 45 democratic
senators right now.
There are two independent senators, Bernie
Sanders and Angus King who caucus with Democrats.
And we could say that's 47 votes right there.
Now there is a question as to will every,
you know, the Senate has some very centrist
or we could even call them conservative Democrats,
Joe mansion for example, will Joe mansion
vote to convict Donald Trump on impeachment?
I'm not sure.
So we may even not have all 47 Democrats to
count on on the other side because you need
a two thirds vote to convict on impeachment.
Two-thirds being with a hundred senators,
it's 67.
Uh, that means you need to pick up 20 Republican
senators who are, forget about, interested
in convicting, even open to that idea.
I don't think they exist.
Uh, and let's go through down.
Let's go down that path now in a couple of
different ways.
First of all, Republican senators are just
going to do what's politically advantageous.
And that means in terms of their reelection,
in terms of balancing that with maintaining
a, a position in Donald Trump's good graces,
et cetera.
Uh, if they put their finger to the wind,
and we know from polling that nearly two thirds
of Republican voters said, not only am I not
against Trump right now, there's nothing Trump
could even hypothetically do that would turn
me against him.
When two thirds of Republican voters, 62%,
almost two thirds say that, why would a Republican
Senator vote to convict when Republican voters
would likely punish them for that decision?
The caveat to this is that we've heard, you
know, a former Senator Jeff flake said he
thinks potentially two dozen or more, I think
30 was the number of Republican senators might
be willing to convict Trump on impeachment.
What, who was he talking about?
What is he talking about?
We don't know.
More recently, democratic Senator Chris Murphy
from Connecticut said that he can count them
on one hand, but they exist.
Republicans who he believes would be willing
to convict Donald Trump.
And we went through the list always on that
list is Senator Susan Collins from Maine.
Although despite her vocalizing sometimes
some opposition to the Republican orthodoxy,
in the end, she usually ends up being a tool
of perpetuating the Republican orthodoxy,
the Brett Kavanaugh hearings being an example
of that.
Anytime we talk about there is a Republican
who might go the other way.
Lisa Murkowski's name comes up from Alaska.
Mitt Romney, who is now a Senator in Utah,
has had some public disagreements with Donald
Trump.
They were friends and they had turtle soup
or whatever it was, frog legs and turtle soup.
Then they were not friends and Trump ridiculed
him, whatever.
Romney has talked, uh, before, uh, when he,
when I believe Romney was asked about Republican
Congressman Justin Amash a mash, I forget
how he pronounces his name, Justin mash saying,
Hey, listen, what Trump's doing is wrong.
We've got to impeach.
Romney said, I respect what he's doing or
what he's doing is brave or courageous or
something like that.
But that's not for me.
So even though Romney's name is being floated
as a possibility, is that likely?
I don't know how Republicans get 20 senators
to say, we're going to vote to convict.
So then let's carry that out.
January goes by and Donald Trump is acquitted
in a Senate impeachment trial.
Then what Trump convicts a Trump rather a
campaigns on vindication.
Does that work?
Certainly non acquittal, despite not necessarily
being vindication because it's going to be
a party line thing, it likely will reinvigorate.
Uh, some voters who voted for Trump in 2016
are not thrilled with Trump's performance
since being inaugurated.
Maybe would have stayed home, probably would
not vote for a Democrat in 2020, but maybe
it would've just stayed home.
They may say, wow, this guy, they've gone
after this guy on Russia now.
They went after him on Ukraine and he was
acquitted.
I've got to get out and support him because
after all this, I don't want a Democrat getting
in.
This guy's been through the ringer that is
likely to invigorates that, that ideology
in at least some 2016 Trump voters.
Then it becomes Ken use what is obviously
going to be a, an a priori, a non conviction
by a Senate.
Republicans, can they use that to say, guys,
we've got to get out and vote.
We, we went through the hearings, we looked
at the evidence.
We did what we could because we control the
house, but the Senate simply will not see
reason.
We now need to vote.
It will then be the end of January or early
February.
It will only be nine months from that election.
We will start to have the Iowa caucuses and
then the New Hampshire primary leading up
to super Tuesday and all of those, the timing
may, and I just don't know.
The timing may really inspire a lot of uh,
left winners, particularly those who maybe
have not voted because remember half the country
doesn't vote.
It may inspire them to get involved and say,
this can't be, I've been sitting on the sidelines.
I gave them the opportunity to get this guy
out with impeachment for what he's done.
I need to now go and vote in November.
Will, that enthusiasm lasts for nine months.
I don't know.
Voting enthusiasm is a fickle and difficult
to predict thing.
So that's my assessment of the next.
What is roughly going to be 11 months.
Again, we had to film this before the house
actually having that full vote.
It may not yet have happened when you listen
to this, it may already have happened when
you watch this, but we will pick this story
up on Monday.
We will take your phone calls.
I will answer you
the questions that we've got.
A great Friday show coming up,